(Niko) Productive morning here in Corridor Digital. (Sam) Alright, let's just get what goes, aim it at Nick.
So we have a certain thing going on in the office where, certain people, when they come over, will attack us with Nerf guns.
(Niko still) All we have right now is little piddly Nerf guns to protect us.
And we need to step up our game. Who doesn't like making traps? Ever since you watched Home Alone
You've always wanted to make a trap, right?
Well, we're going to build a Nerf mine.
It's also going to be a minefield for everybody else who's in The Game of Life because we're me saying the word "mine" a lot.
But I'm not in the game.
And if you're wondering what the heck The Game of Life is, anytime someone says the word "mine"
They have to do ten push-ups. Also once you're in it
You're in it for life. So, I went online, I did a bunch of research
I found a couple different models on Thingiverse and there's one in particular that I like. It's by this guy propter hawk(?)
It's a remix of another design by Ian Great and an Anton the Red Beard. You have like, a dart holder in a like
A plunger and a bunch of rubber bands and a pin and when somebody steps on a tripwire it pulls the pin and goes boof and shoots all the darts
So I was actually the last one here in the office last night working on this lookup table pack that we're gonna be selling on
creativepresets.com
(Link in the description below.)
And I actually set it up to print overnight, so let's go see how it turned out. Nick was really surprised.
(Wren) It looks like you printed a revolver. (Niko) I'm gonna break these. (Wren) Yeah these look very easy to break.
At my own nerve pushers slightly don't crank on the probably fine. I think he liked all of that
Yeah
You can see it when you look at the bottom of the glass you can see where it starts coming off so Ren just give
Us a recap with it. What has Niko printed, man?
Niko has pursued a Nerf claymore
Alright piece 1. This is the trigger
See when I pull the bottom here. You can see it coming off
not gonna
Do you think it's gonna shatter? No. I'm not free to gonna do like one of these things are like
I have lots of control Wren.
Risky business so do we have rubber bands (Niko) yes, we do need rubber bands. I don't know if you have any the way this works
Boom the nerf tights sit in this thing, and then this is loaded with rubber bands
And then there's a pin here that will hold it in place
When the pin gets pulled that slams forward, and it launches all the nerfs, nerfs all the nerfs. Oh, man
Where's all the darts go finish putting this together here? Is that the thing from your bedroom?
I'm moving out. I got it. I got a new place so the first time in 10 years are moving
I've been living in downtown in this very building you were living on the other side
Yeah in fact your bedrooms right there
I want a house in LA and it's a huge move, and I finally moved everything out
And I'm finding there's lots of things that I had
That I no longer need or use or whatever and this gun happen to be one of them
So here's what happened the entire time that Sam lived upstairs
He had my gun on his wall putting it back in my hand
Yeah, yeah, I'm cleaning up the place. I'm like hey isn't this yours and he's like. Thank gosh
This is actually a real gun it's super antique. It's a Lee Enfield. It's like a British gun yeah, normally
There's like a small magazine or something that goes here, but you can see it's all sealed up right here because this one was
Modified as effectively a riot gun the chamber of the weapon has been modified to shoot 410 shotgun
Shells with these very thin tiny shotgun shells and it's only one shot at a time you put the shell and right there
It in and shoots, so I've been wanting to find a way to
cast some fairly simple gun props Ali Anfield
This is like just nondescript enough so that I could like change a couple things around it
And it doesn't need to be perfect at all, but like once you paint and good for the background cool old piece of history
Almost most expensive rubber bands
Between
Produce it goes between you hear this little divot and here's a little bit like this mm-hmm like that. Oh, man
It's armed right now, I don't like to get stabbed by the toothpick you won't hear you might
Productive morning here in corridor digital
So we can get a bigger like stickers, and I'll go back in further all right, let's see how it goes aim it at Nick
I think like there's gonna be a little bit more intense yeah considering how much
We need some more bongos, dude we're the few oh, this is a toothpick. It's broken
I think we need to use a nail amigo. I don't want a nail to go flying into somebody's like leg we can clip
Okay
The easy answer to that is you can find the best Lutz available at creator presets comm actually they're not the best
That's available I would actually give those to other luck of table pax
But the pretty dang good because we worked on I'm here in corridor digital some of our most popular videos
We have made presets of the color grades for you guys, so if you want to check them out
We have a 9 look-up tables for you over at Crater presets. Calm. Go check them out for yourself link in the description below
You go have a test one go
Okay they were there they saw it it was embarrassing
There are nails work, right
I've doubled the bongos the bongo ratio is far far too low put your nail in there
God damn dude. I'm gonna get the punctured
No, dude this thing is about to explode once I like
Dangerous like whoever designed this tram is in the same
Let me show you why this is terrible flip this boards and it releases the nail so the nails pushing this way the nail itself
gets pushed
forward at the same speed and velocity in
Everything that the darts are being pushed at I think the darts are going to hit the wall with the amount of bongos
We've added. I think the nail is gonna make it halfway to the wall
I think the nail is gonna flop on the ground right there anything that doesn't make it halfway to the wall. I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna
oh
The nail went backwards
It's so unpredictable
The nail was flung and they'll Orange my god my Nerf darts and nails. I know so it's technically it's
Yeah the Hasbro guys are gonna love this these are all the pitches
As you might know we were in New York this past weekend for the Madden 18 launch event and you also might know that we
Got Xboxes. He said in the video let us know if you think Carmichael should have it for all the hard work
he's been doing on the channel, or if we should give it away and
Honestly, I'm super impressed by how many of you said Carmichael deserves the Xbox. That's right Carmichael
You are now the proud owner of a brand new Xbox one
LCS 10 for scorpions, I thought it stood for Scorpio or whatever it turns out, it's just slim so
Yeah, I haven't had an Xbox since high school
Thank you everyone. I have a video game console. I'm in the future how much line do we want you
Want to do a test in here just like on this shelf. Please the trip
It doesn't I'm saying you could write and just see if it works. There's like right here
Perfect okay, so you're gonna arm it?
It was
Nothing shout out some Horace Mann paper candle is gonna be a little bit more safe
Here, so you grab the strings on the other side of this door
Will just yell Wren we need battery help. It's a taut wire life is filled with uncertainties sometimes
You just got to take a risk especially when you can entertain other people in the process okay?
Are we ready?
It's so obvious
Turn the phone still picking up that shine don't look at it. I mean if it doesn't work then try something else
I'm so bad at like getting people to come in here though. There you go here
Just come with me as I talk to like hey. Let me get Sam Sam come in here Sam's gonna. No
no, no, I think I'll just
Gonna lay here
I'm not standing there well first time you stopped
Slowing down with Sam get slowing down to its distraction nobody's gonna. Talk about something
Distract it we need training else in here
So we're all gonna focus on something over here, which will make Ranma at the door will just burst in
You see here in you know what this thing is hey red hey run you run?
I feel betrayed, but rest that was good. I didn't see that at all. Oh my god. Did you get here with the nail?
They tried to get me but
Problem this is baby. He tried to bring me in from the front
And then we realized we're all in here like we have someone to focus look in here
You know yeah now the way you did it work. Well like you might